They're really big, successful creators.
They always have this either in their hand over here,
like clip to their hat or clip to their shirt.
I'm gonna show you why. I'm gonna plug it into my phone right now.
I'm not gonna stop the video at all.
I'm gonna plug it in and show you how it changes your audio. Listen.
Okay, you hear me now?
Now watch how far I can walk away.
Watch, I'm gonna keep.
Actually, I can't walk backwards because it's a little hill,
but watch, I'm gonna keep talking
and I think you can still see me.
I think you can still see me,
and I know you can still hear me,
cause that's how good this microphone works.
Watch, I'm gonna go all the way across the street.
I think you can still see me.
I'm over here. So if you're wanting to make better content,
one of the easiest things you can do is get a microphone
so people can hear you
and you can be a little creative and not so stuck.
It's like right here if you want one.